[Music]
thank you thank you all very much for
the kind introduction
Dean and thank you all for a warm
welcome it is wonderful to be we're with
you it is a privilege to remind you what
a privilege each of you has by being in
the chair that you're in whether you're
a student faculty staff or photographer
this is the you heard that there he is
right there
he can vouch that we moved that was it
20 veterans through and 30 veterans
through less than 30 seconds per so I
mean it the all-stars are everywhere
here at Stanford and it really is a
privilege to be back here that although
the first time at the business school
and George thanks for doing this and to
all of you for twisting my arm until I
finally showed up thank you sir for
joining us and for your tremendous
service to our country
General Petraeus before we begin we have
many veterans with us here in the
audience if I may I'd like to ask all
the veterans present please to rise so
that we may recognize you
[Applause]
I had a chance to meet with most of them
beforehand and obviously thanked him for
all they've done particularly since 9/11
almost all of them are members of what
we termed the new greatest generation
and very much deserve the recognition
that you all have kindly just provided
to them but it was wonderful to be back
these are members of my tribe I was the
Sheikh of the tribe in various places
along the way and great to spend time
with them again but great to be here you
know I'm in a new tribe now the business
world tried the private equity world it
actually has been great I have learned
that the highest calling in life after
government service actually is private
equity I'm not joking
it really is I actually believe in the
concept where you provide not just
capital but expertise assistance support
guidance and all the rest of that to two
firms mostly private although we do do
public equities by the way I must
confess that I took the position with
KKR without a complete understanding of
the difference between private and
public equities I've sought to learn a
few things in the last five years but
you're there's a great business world
out there for those of you who haven't
been in it already and the the inherent
strengths of the u.s. system are quite
substantial despite the occasional
shortcoming or noise that we may
experience as well okay sir we will
definitely get to that part of your
career to kick things off I'd like to
start with some examples of leadership
and judgment from your military career
you described the ideal leadership style
as adaptive and affirmative drawing from
your own experiences could you elaborate
on what that style looks like in
practice
sure I mean adaptive is pretty
straightforward it essentially means
that you are learning faster than the
competition in the battlefield we
literally had a saying it was in the
counterinsurgency Field Manual in fact
that we drafted when I was a 3-star back
in the States between the three
four star tours in Iraq we said that the
side that learns the fastest typically
prevails and the same is true in any
endeavor any walk of life so you're
constantly trying to figure out how can
you learn faster how can you become a
learning individual and how can you
ensure that your organization
collectively is learning and it's not
enough just to say it or to repeat it or
to emphasize it write about it you
actually have to have formal mechanisms
to sit down and consider what is it that
we should have learned I might in fact
write here just sort of talk about
because everything keeps coming back to
what I've described as the tasks of a
strategic leader there are four of these
tasks they are equally valid in the
business world the military world
intelligence world any world essentially
the strategic leader for an organization
or sometimes co-leaders is the case at
KKR and many other businesses is that
the tasks are to get the big ideas right
in other words to get the right strategy
to communicate those effectively
throughout the breadth and depth of the
organization to oversee their
implementation and then to determine how
you have to refine the big ideas and do
it all over again and again and again
and facilitating adaptation and being
adapt the leader means that that fourth
step is a formal step this isn't
something that you just sort of do while
you're running or in the shower moments
of reflection or something like that you
have to actually sit down and there's a
structured process by which those who
are who you're privileged to lead and it
could be one hundred sixty five thousand
American men and women in uniform and
the surge or two hundred and fifty
thousand and Central Command or you know
it can be sixty people in a start-up but
the strategic leader has to get those
tasks right regardless I often said that
the surge in Iraq that mattered most was
not the surge of forces we added 25,000
30,000 forces to an existing nearly
hundred and forty thousand and drove
violence down by eighty five percent
eighteen months after it had been going
up and up and up and up and up and the
reason for that was not the extra forces
it wasn't that surge it was the surge of
ideas the big ideas and every one of the
big ideas was a hundred and eighty
degrees different from what we were
doing before most significantly was that
we'd been withdrawing from living with
the population getting out of the
people's faces as it was termed because
we thought we were part of the problem
instead of part of the solution and
because the Prime Minister wanted us to
hand off more rapidly to Iraqis tasks
that they couldn't handle but we were
consolidating on big bases and the more
we did that you ended up with a
situation that was captured brilliantly
in a New York Times story the title of
which was driving around Baghdad waiting
to get blown up this is how a sergeant
first class described what he was doing
on a daily basis in Iraq because they'd
basically leave their big base that go
drive around the neighborhood a few
times every now and then they'd get
blown up and then they'd go back to the
big base generally for dinner or for the
night obviously that does not provide
security to the people which is the
number one task and the foundation on
which all else is built if you don't
have security obviously you don't you
can't do anything else and keep in mind
that when the surge decision was made in
December of 2006 there were 53 dead
civilian bodies due to violence every 24
hours just in Baghdad that's the capital
city of the country obviously there's
nothing going on except for survival so
again you've got to improve security and
big idea number one was you have to live
with the people to secure them and again
number one task is to secure and
actually to serve the people next was by
the way stop handing off the Iraqis take
it back over even if not formally third
was you have you can't kill or capture
your way out of an industrial strains
insurgent so you have to reconcile with
as many of the rank-and-file as you
possibly can that meant sitting down yep
with people who had our blood on their
hands something that the battalion
brigade commanders brought to my
attention as you might imagine but and I
would remind them that this is how these
endeavors end so Big Ideas our crew
by the way they don't usually hit you on
the head like Newton's apple
fully-formed if you sit under the right
tree you tend to get hit on the head by
a seed of a big idea and then you have
to sort of shape it like a clay object
play ideally you do it
transparently very inclusively because
you want everybody feeling as if they're
inside the tent because you know what
happens if they're outside the tent and
so that process and then it's iterative
as well you're constantly refining the
big ideas but what got me started on
this is again the need for that fourth
step which is a formal process in our
case we had all these lessons learned
teams on the battlefield I used to
remind them that they weren't learning
lessons they just identified lessons but
I wasn't going to change the signage on
all of their headquarters that would
cost too much but they just needed to
understand that a lesson has only
learned once it's actually incorporated
in the big ideas communicated in the
mission statement the the civil-military
campaign plan all the rest of this and
then overseen and again there's many
many subtasks for each one of these by
the way I've actually spelled this out
for those who want to get more on it
there was at the Harvard Kennedy School
the Belfer Center has a website that we
created on strategic leadership just
Google Petraeus on Street strategic
leadership at the Belfer Center so we've
worked our way through that and so again
the adaptive component is something
that's not just a state of mind or a
phrase or an ambition it's a formal
process and by the way the great
business leaders of America when you
talk to them typically have something
just like that and I'll give the example
of Netflix perhaps Reed Hastings is one
of the extraordinary leaders of America
he's Jeff Bezos others that are just
incredible at being able to continually
reinvent the big ideas or to develop
additional big ideas so if you think
about Netflix the original big idea was
we're gonna put blockbuster out of
business by mailing videos to customers
and movies so they that's the big idea
they communicate it not too big a firm
then they oversee the implementation by
the way there's metrics there's the
battle
how their leader spends his or her time
and then they get down to the bottom and
after a couple years they say well you
know what blockbuster went out of
business but now everybody's mailing CDs
to their customers so what do we do now
new big idea we are going to download
broadband speeds are fast enough now
consumers customers can download videos
so that's the new big idea communicator
to oversee it get down here 2 years
later this has been fantastic
you know we're scaling and everything
else but now everybody else is offering
downloaded content so what do we do now
well we create our own content 100
million dollars on house of cards alone
communicate it do it get down here gosh
this is fantastic but now everybody's
doing that as well so what do we do now
well now let's get into blockbuster MIDI
movies you know the real big productions
and they've done seriously well there
too they've won a bunch of awards at the
con film cluster well I think of the
Academy Awards or whatever I wasn't that
impressed by the first movie that came
out which had Brad Pitt playing Stanley
McChrystal general McChrystal is that
McChrystal has a much better sense of
humor than Brad Pitt ever did and he's
not wooden and you know he sort of go
around like a little automat on besides
I was really hoping I've been hoping
that Brad Pitt would hold out to play me
but there was a little cameo in there
but the guy he's a bit tall come on I
mean you know if that tall guy could
play Henry Henry Kravis in barbarians at
the gates you know Brad good editorial
license it's it actually I had a tiny
cameo in that movie I've actually never
watched it in all honesty I watched the
preview or what-have-you but there's a
so the guy who was the gladiator played
me briefly in that movies anyway so this
it worked out a little bit for the part
but you know anyway so that's the
adaptive piece
affirmative leadership is is a construct
that is based on a belief that everybody
you're privileged to lead wants to be
all that he or she can be that they
really do want to be the very best now
look if you're honest you know outside
of Stanford and Harvard and a few other
places that may or may not be completely
true it still is the way that you ought
to act until folks prove that you should
act that way and so what I mean by
affirmative leadership is you know
instead of saying hey George you better
have that damn report on my desk by
Monday at noon or I'll have a piece of
your backside
I say George man I heard people are
talking already about this report you're
gonna get to me on noon and on Monday
and wow I'm really excited about it
already they say it's really going to be
terrific gonna set the world on fire I
don't know if I'll be able to sleep on
Sunday night I'm so excited about it do
you want to double size you're single
space you know you know look I've just
put a whole you know big rock in his
rucksack he knows he's really got to
produce now but I did it affirmative Lee
rather than negatively and so that's the
concept I think that we talk about
they're fantastic a lot of useful
leadership lessons there
don't forget pre-emptive praise so this
is where you walk into Prime Minister
Maliki in the Iraqi White House and you
say Prime Minister I no need to say
anything I have heard that you are
pursuing this particular initiative and
that you're working out the construct of
it and how to implement it and all that
don't need to say anything Prime
Minister because of course he hasn't no
intention to do this at all but you just
keep going and going and going until you
realize he's finally sort of
capitulating Petraeus will never stop
until I just say okay yes I am pursuing
that initiative and then of course he
does and it succeeds and he said man I
had this initiative general wouldn't had
a great initiative that I had again
consider that approach as well
I wanted to return a little bit to your
military career you've talked a bit
about the surge and you know I think all
of us could benefit a lot from
understanding how you at this point you
stake your career on this on this
strategy how did you handle any doubts
or concerns you might have had about the
strategy well first of all I mean at the
end of the day it's all about results
and you know I was born and raised by a
old crusty Dutch c-captain Dutch
American and a librarian mother and I
remember when I'd come home from school
or something like that and you know it
wasn't always or it wasn't exactly what
it should have been he just sort of
looking and I'd start offering well you
know I just had so much going on in the
sports and all those you just sort of
look at me until I stop and say results
boy and results at the end of the day
was what enabled us to continue the
surge we had six months basically to
show that this was going to work I knew
that during the confirmation hearing I
was really sort of forced to agree to
come back at six months then I came back
at three months but behind closed door
is very different dynamics and when all
the cameras are on it was sort of a
scene like we saw setting up this
morning on the news for Mark Zuckerberg
I mean just the whole well is full of
cameras but by that six-month mark eight
of the final eleven week saw a
precipitate drop in violence in so now
you have something that is very very
substantial and then it kept on going
and ultimately as I mentioned it was
down by eighty five percent over 18
months so at the end of the day it's
really about results now what did I do
upfront well I sought to convey to them
this is what we're going to do these are
the big ideas these is this is how
they're different from what we have been
doing the interesting thing is that I
mean nobody gave us any guidance for
that I mean people think that we were
sent over there to implement a quote
comprehensive civil military
counterinsurgency campaign not at all
and we just selected confirmed and get
over there and fix
but we'd had the this fortune experience
of 15 months where I was back between
the three and four star tours during
which we did the counterinsurgency Field
Manual two special editions of military
review counter insurgency writing
contest reshaped everything about the so
called road to deployment the very first
seminar all of the tasks for leaders
collective training individual soldiers
organizational structures equipment
everything so that they were also much
better prepared but we had then the
intellectual foundation that gave us the
confidence to reverse what we were doing
in again sort of ironically or
paradoxically a month before the surge
decision was made the president went out
to Amman Jordan he couldn't even land in
Iraq it was too dangerous and the prime
minister of Iraq went over there to meet
with him and they actually agreed to
accelerate what we had been doing
throughout 2006 which was again to
consolidate on big bases handoff to the
Iraqis release detainees all the stuff
that we reversed completely I actually
wasn't aware of that fully until I got
on the ground and was confronted by the
national security advisor of Iraq over
that and at the end of which in the very
first week ambassador Crocker wasn't
even there and I said doctor and I knew
him from the three-star tour I said if
it is the intention of the prime
minister to take those actions in other
words to accelerate what we have been
doing and I might remind you that we've
assessed that the strategy is failing so
you're going to fail faster if that's
your objective please ensure that the
prime minister knows that he should
convey that to President Bush tomorrow
and the normally scheduled
videoconference which I understand the
commander and ambassador always attend
but he should know in advance that if he
chooses to do that he is going to do it
without me because I will be on the next
plane to Washington and I intend to take
the policy with me that was a fairly big
deal that was sort of what you might
term it all in a moment and I didn't
sleep real well that night until I took
ambien and then
and then set the next day on the edge of
my chair the whole way through and never
heard anything from it again and so we
were able to go ahead and implement what
it was that that we intended to do so
you try to explain what what it is
you're going to do then obviously as you
start implementing it you start trying
to lay out for them this is what it's
achieving by the way the challenge was
and I told Congress this in advance I
said it's going to get harder before it
gets easier because we're going back
into the neighborhoods we're going to
have to fight to get back into most of
these in fact it was a drill you
literally had to come in at last light
and have it completely established with
concrete walls all around it by the time
the Sun came up because you'd have at
least one sometimes two suicide car
bombers coming at you as quickly as they
could they could generate them and so it
was a very very challenging period and
in fact violence did go up casualties
went up but then thankfully as I said
they crested and then started but
already Iraqis civilian casualties were
going down and other very key indices
and metrics were going down so again at
the end of the day though as you all
know already and and have had reaffirmed
here I'm sure in your courses
it's about result it is about the bottom
line it is about laying that out and
understanding why it has done what it
has done so that was a time when you
very powerfully delivered the results
you've also had to deal with personal
and professional setbacks in the public
spotlight could you give us some advice
about how to deal with those setbacks
yeah in public yeah look I mean first of
all it just you just have to understand
that life is not full of high-five
moments there are setbacks there are
collective organizations screw things up
individuals in those organizations we
had a good petunia Sarge at one time
well-meaning who decided to use pages of
a Koran for target practice at a small
range that we had at every Combat
Outpost and local worker at rocky worker
found it you know immediately reported
it and boom and so you know you end up
going to the prime minister
apologizing publicly the president
United States called I mean these things
happen and then you know you'll make
mistakes of your own
try not to obviously but but that
happened and obviously I did and
experienced that and I think that you
know what you do in a situation like
that or any situation where there has
been a mistake or a setback or a
shortcoming is you know I determined
specifically what did happen
why own it publicly acknowledged it
apologized word if that's required and
most importantly determine how to
mitigate the risk of this recurring in
the future look we spent that I mean
that entire surge tour was spent frankly
with that process going fairly regularly
I remember at the end of it to give you
a sense of what that experience was like
I had this fantastic chief warrant
officer three or four who was my he was
the head of the security detachment that
we had I don't know if we had somewhere
between forty and sixty people something
like that that most of those rotated
because there again I was there for
nineteen and a half months on that tour
but he was always he stayed and by the
way he went with me to CENTCOM and he
went with me to Afghanistan tremendous
guy anyway we're coming to the end of
the surge and and every now and then at
night we lived in a huge old palace
complex and it was had a man-made lake
in the center of it it's quite vast I
mean we had a six mile running route
inside this compound but I'd go for a
walk
late at night before turning in and just
to sort of gather thoughts and think
about things and we just walk along the
water and then come back and he would
always go with me we didn't need any
buddy else but just to make sure and he
had communications as well and normally
we didn't talk and like that beyond a
few pleasantries and this time we were
about halfway through it and I attorney
he said sir can I ask a question I said
sure Keith he said what has it been like
you know you what's it been like to
command a surge you're criticized you
were vilified you're attacked by a
full-page ad in the New York
personally by an activist organization
on the day of your biggest testimony I
mean a sort of we've had tough
casualties we've had this we've had that
but I got it's worked and now everybody
even their fiercest critics acknowledge
it you know what's it been like
and I said chief it has been the most
awesomely awesome of experiences on a
good day and we had less than this
number of good days so I mean it's a
grinding experience and leadership is
like that again leadership is not always
in in an upswing cycle you know we're
we're we were actually trying to remind
ourselves at KKR that were a hundred and
four or 105 months into this particular
recovery it's it's approaching the
second longest in our history
I think 120 is the longest ever we have
people in the firm who have never been
in that firm when there has been a
downturn and so we're actually talking
about wargaming the winter is coming
scenarios I didn't know what that was
and they had to explain to me that
there's this series called Game of
Thrones or something I guess winter is
always coming or something but but
that's so we're actually you you and
again we know there's gonna be tough
times during that and so what is it you
do to prepare for that how do you how do
you you know prepare yourself personally
for that kind of experience but it is
it's a grinding experience and the more
public it is the more you know you've
been run up the flagpole the more that
is the case and then those those
grinding experiences you clearly need to
have a lot of internal strength since
since you stepped down from the CIA
you've worked very hard to build a new
career and continue serving the country
in those difficult years that followed
how did you summon the strength to carry
on well I think you know you got to
realize that life goes on or it should
and then you start figuring out okay you
know what are the options what is it
that would be fulfilling rewarding you
know help pay for the grandkids
education and a few
things like that and in my case it was
the idea of intellectual stimulation
I don't mind travel I mean we just I was
in 22 countries last year alone one of
them I think six or seven times and so
you know busting your butt is is okay I
mean I've got many of my West Point
classmates are literally completely
retired some of them are literally down
in golf communities in Florida riding
around in golf carts and try to persuade
me to come down there and you know what
an awesome thing that is and I think
that's where I might actually pull out
the service pistol and consider it but I
mean I you know you can you I actually
outlined a leadership book it was titled
relentless : leadership lessons learned
- - some of the hard way and so but I
was very very fortunate I mean people
called immediately and said hey when
you're ready to resurface caught up come
on up I knew Henry Kravis before that
was one of the he was one of those but
there are a number of others so there
were tremendous options but then I
deliberately also chose to do some that
were in the academic world I taught for
three and a half years every week
actually at the Honors College of the
City University of New York did it for
$1 a year the first year when again that
same or one of the activist
organizations objected to the great
salary they were gonna pay me but it was
about again the intellectual stimulation
the fun of interacting with students it
was of course called the North American
decades which is what I contended
follows the American Century and
precedes the Chinese or Asian century
and the number of s is on the end would
depend on how effective Washington is at
turning legislative regulatory and
policy headwinds into tailwind
particularly with a focus on there were
four revolutions that we're we explored
with a policy perspective the IT
revolution which is the basis for most
of the others the energy revolution
unique to the US and our circumstances
in a tribute to the US because it's only
happened here the manufacturing
revolution and then the life sciences
revolution it was just great
and then I have a chair at USC where I
spend a week per semester including
hosting a startup event most of the
times that I'm there sometimes it's
every other but we bring in 45 or so
venture capitalists I'm actually
personally invested in 15 different
startups which I just enjoyed doing in
part because I really enjoy young
leaders with great big ideas it's very
exciting and then you can help them then
you have the firms in which were
invested I hosted the co-founder of lyft
for dinner last night here we have a big
Menlo Park office so it's a great
stimulating life I'm also on the speaker
speaking circuit you know the highest
form of white-collar crime in America I
have I want you to know I've waived my
outrage of speaking fee for this great
privilege but we are grateful for that
and then there's you know the 4/4 think
tanks that I'm actively engaged with and
then about a dozen veterans
organizations and so plus we have a
grand new brand new granddaughter and
our son's dog he's actually up at
Harvard Business School doing the JD MD
JD MBA program and and daughter and
son-in-law I live nearby so it I've been
very very fortunate but you know you you
I was gonna use this at the end but I
might use it here luck and I bidding
I don't know accused of or described as
being lucky at a number of different
ventures over the years including
command and General Staff College
graduate school you know Iraq and all
these others and you know my response to
that not necessarily directly when
people are saying that but is to offer
that I think luck is what happens when
preparation meets opportunity and I
really sought to prepare for these
opportunities I'm very very serious
about that and you know you don't want
to sound presumptuous at all but when I
will be back when I was a second
lieutenant you know I never really
expected you're gonna get to this but by
God you know I wanted
to be prepared if the opportunity came
along and I'd been pressed by this
statement that Napoleon used to say that
every corporal has a field marshals
baton in his rucksack in other words you
know be ready you never know corporal
could be called you know Petraeus for
field marshal and so we were actually
jumping with the british paratroopers
when i was in my first assignment and we
had an afternoon off we jumped all
morning and the guy said well you
wouldn't my fellow British lieutenant
host said you want to go to the pub and
I said yeah but let's stop by the this
service store they have stores outside
all the bases in which they sell old kit
new kit and all the kinds of bells and
whistles that you put on your uniform
and I said you know I'd like to see if
they have a field marshals baton used
sort of looked at me strange but anyway
we went in there it was run by an old
retired regimental sergeant major these
guys are super crusty and he said well
you know what do you have and I said
both sir major I wonder if you have any
used field marshals batons oh he said
fresh out of those mate but you know we
have this little swagger stick and I
actually bought the swagger stick I tied
it to the frame of my rucksack which I
used all the way through I think
two-star division command and with green
cord 550 cord as the veterans here would
note burned on either end and tied off
of the proper knot and nobody else could
really see it but it was there for me
and every time I lifted that rucksack
which had to be thousands of times over
the years I took it on and took it off
and put it on it was there reminding me
that you know you'd need to be ready you
need to be prepared your individual
study or experiences your professional
development all the rest of that stuff
be serious about that and you'd do it
you know with a smile with a joke with a
try to be self-deprecating or whatever
but at the end of the day in the back of
your mind has to be that this actually
could happen and to be truthful I mean
but for a few months here or there at
different junctures none of it may have
happened but you know that's what you do
in my post government stuff you know did
I prepare for that gosh I don't know I
mean I did do the academic stuff I did
not at the
I'm thinking that was what I was gonna
do mingle with people who invited me to
speak at their their dining room in New
York but mostly just because I was
trying to convey to people what we were
doing and these were influencers and a
great opportunity by the way a great you
know so people asked how did you get to
know Henry Kravis and I said well his
wife who's a serious intellectual in her
own right
shot me an email out of the blue one
time he's a three or four star and I was
gonna be in New York doing something the
Council on Foreign Relations she saw it
and noticed that there was no dinner
offered and so she said you know you got
to eat why don't you eat at our place
and we have a pretty good track record
of people coming who were invited in
fact she said you can ask us to invite
people so I said super thanks so much
Marie josée could you invite Henry
Kissinger Mayor Bloomberg Police
Commissioner Kelly I think was Richard
Holbrooke and then a couple of noted
intellectuals and they did and every
single one of them showed up and I
learned later you know if you don't show
up at Henry Kravis table they do a
leveraged buyout of your firm the next
morning
speaking of preparation we have a class
at Stanford called managing difficult
conversations in the spirit of this
class let's imagine that you are
President Petraeus you're sitting across
a North Korean dictator Kim Jimin it's
the first face-to-face meeting of the
leaders of the two countries how would
you make this conversation successful
well again this is all about preparation
it's all about detailed study and under
nuanced understanding of what has
transpired before what do we think they
have met when they have used the term
nuclear disarmament in the past hint
it's not what we think it means and on
and on and on all the dynamics as much
as you can learn about an individual who
is the most difficult intelligence
target in the world because he's inside
the Hermit Kingdom famously difficult
place to operate to say that it is a
quote denied area as the term is in the
intelligence world would be a bit of an
understand
so I think this is all about very very
rigorous preparation very rigorous
talking points with branches and sequels
you know if this then that and and so
forth but you know certainly also trying
to establish a relationship to see if
that is possible is there really can you
actually have some kind of meaningful
strategic relationship I am a huge
believer in efforts to have a strategic
dialogue I believe that you should we
should be having that with China it's
difficult if the key diplomats are
changing at the rate and the key
national security team members are
changing at the rate that they have been
but this is crucial I mean if you think
about what people like Henry Kissinger
were able to do or others over the years
that had the big breakthroughs this came
after a lot of back and forth you know
you talk about luck being what happens
when preparation meets opportunity Henry
Kissinger used to run a summer I think
it was called the summer center of
seminar of the senior seminar I went
back I actually one point read
everything that he wrote including the
books about him which described how he
prepared for these opportunities that he
had during the eight years that he was
national security adviser and then
Secretary of State it was very very
deliberate he would sought to meet every
you know junior leader around the world
attract him to Harvard have interaction
with them get to know them ahead of time
and then of course once he was in office
he'd just beat himself up on planes and
everywhere else personally engaging with
them and again having true strategic
discussion discussions now we have to be
very careful to have limited aspirations
for the results of a first meeting
noting that you know that that Kim
jong-un had never even met the president
of China the country with which North
Korea has ninety percent of its trade
back and forth until just a couple of
weeks ago so he's also not the most
schooled of individuals when it comes to
this but look this there is hope out of
this I think this is not a forlorn hope
and by the way some of this is the
result of the so-called maximum pressure
strategy that has been pursued I'm not
saying that I
have used all of the rhetoric that has
been deployed at different times or that
message discipline has been a sterling
feature of everything that's taking
place here but the fact is that a
willingness to rattle the saber has
gotten Chinese attention that has forced
them together with UN Security Council
resolutions that are unprecedented to
actually really tighten down on the
umbilical cord that literally keeps the
lights on in Pyongyang and again 90% of
it running to and from China so that has
been a key catalyst for what is
happening and folks who have been part
of that deserves some of the credit for
that without question and and now we'll
see if again this very rigorous
preparation can be undertaken in order
to capitalize on the opportunity that
that results and you've spoken a bit
about how this saber rattling is taking
place very publicly with a lot of media
coverage it seems that there is a real
role for the the conflict and its
resolution in in the way that the media
are managed drawing from your own
experience could you talk a bit about
how you how PR and image management yeah
have shaped your strategy and its
implementation sure let me start by just
saying again we had big ideas for
everything during the surge and but not
just in Iraq but in Afghanistan as well
many some of them carried over to
Afghanistan but I also note that the
very first time I did an assessment of
Afghanistan which is when my way home
from a three star tour in Iraq as
secretary Rumsfeld to request when i
briefed the secretary on return home the
very first slide was titled Afghanistan
does not equal Iraq and laid out all the
different ways in which it's
tremendously different and hence the
reason when I was Central Command
commander and then the nominee for
command in Afghanistan that I said that
we are not going to be able to do in
Afghanistan what we did in Iraq we can't
flip this place there's no way that
changing the big ideas is going to have
such a dramatic you know by the way to
be fair general McChrystal's already
been implementing so I'm going to be
building on
what it is that he has already been
putting into place but the big idea that
I had about dealing with the press was
quite simple it was to be first with the
truth it was again if you have a bad day
we had a tremendous General Officer for
example when I first got there who just
found it difficult to go out to the
podium look these were horrible days
that we're having I mean they blew up a
part of the Parliament they dropped the
old historic bridge right in the centre
of the Tigris River blew up the mosque
again or a minaret of the mosque that
had touched off the violence the
previous year the summer a mosque just
day after day of this kind of stuff and
what you have to do when that happens is
you go out to the podium and you say we
had a horrible day today in Baghdad
there were three markets that were
bombed by four suicide bombers and 250
innocent Iraqis were killed and then you
have to talk about okay what are we
learned from this what are we gonna do
about it by the way what we ultimately
had to do was a wall off these markets
were some of which were a mile long just
on a street and then went several
streets in and they became no Drive
zones and so then we had to start
searching the hand cards but again this
is a level that you have to go to he
found it difficult after a while to go
out and I remember we had a horrible day
in Baghdad one time and went out and
started talking about yes we got the
soccer league is gonna get going again
look there were areas of progress but if
you have a horrible day you don't lead
with that and so we decided at that
point that it was time to allow that
individual to move on because you've got
to be first with the truth just lay it
out and get it out there beyond that I
actually had a briefing that I developed
I think it was again when I was back
from the three star tour and it was
titled dealing with the press and it
started out it said you can't win if you
don't play and I had a whole bunch of
sort of happy examples of me and the
cover of this or this you know kind of
nice stuff and and it all came because I
was open to the press and had Rick
Atkins riding and back of my Humvee to
the fight to Baghdad and this that and
the other thing then it said you can't
lose if you don't play and now there's
some unhappy ones like when I had the
Washington Post
or with me where we decided to reopen a
border with Syria on our own in the
first year first months in fact and we
go out there and cut the ribbon and
there's hundreds of trucks lined up to
come in all with goods for the
marketplace and by the way we'd found
money so that workers of nainawa
province Mosul were gonna be paid by the
way what had happened is we found the
money I found the guy and he said you
know he could didn't have the authority
to pay it but he said but you do I said
you're right I do he said make it an
order so I signed an order to I mean
it's a great no stamp so we went out in
the souk and bought a stamp anyway so
they're gonna pay this workers but with
my clever economics knowledge from grad
school I realized that we were about to
dump more money on a closed economy and
the result of that would be inflation
and so had to get more goods into the
marketplace went to the governor we had
the first election in Iraq we already
had a governor a partner said what do we
do he said have you considered reopening
the border with Syria I said I didn't
even know we closed it remember we
weren't supposed to go to Mosul we
didn't have maps were we didn't have
anything when we were ordered up there
and so we were still doing a lot of
discovery learning so anyway we decided
to open it up we got the legal team with
the UN Security Council resolutions
governing trained in promulgating
instructions a great brigade commander
went out and then the governor I'd go
out and hide a Washington Post reporter
and it was an extraordinary day I mean
it's just it was one of those very very
rare awesome days in Iraq because you've
really made a difference in people's
lives you know there's about a thousand
sheiks there all applauding and thanking
and we're wheeling with Apache
helicopters around and I'm waving you
know the shake of the biggest tribe in
northern Iraq and as we're coming out
this washer and riposte reporter says
general what is this like I mean my god
you've just reopened a border you've
helped the existence of thousands of
people of Western Nainoa province and I
said well you know it's it's it's pretty
exceptional it's sort of like a cross
between being the Pope and the president
you know what the headline in the
Washington Post was the next day
now I survived that so you can't lose if
you don't play and so a lot of people
concluded therefore that you know the
the best press policy is
never never pass up keeping your mouth
shut but then I said but you've got to
play and then held a whole bunch of
examples you know it's not my army it's
America's army and America's mothers and
fathers sons and daughters or whatever
have a right to know what's going on and
we have an obligation to do it so we
walked our way through that and I truly
believe that it was hugely important
there have been people who have gone
through missions and never gave an
on-the-record interview never interacted
with the press never took them with them
we always had people with us it doesn't
mean you're gonna get favorable coverage
it lists least it means that they have
been exposed to it and we brought people
over we brought think tankers over who
had criticized us we brought think
tankers overs who had who had praised
this some of this stuff was hugely
important I remember it was an op-ed
piece by Mike O'Hanlon of Brookings and
his comrade also I guess at Brookings
her AEI that in June or July of the
surge so before we were saying it said
you know the surge just may be working
and by the way he took huge flack for
that except that he proved was proved to
be right so again you've got to engage
not just with the press but with again
with so-called intellectuals influence
makers Stanford Business School you know
whatever it is and we used to do a lot
of that when I was the Central Command
commander back from the surge in Iraq we
would take usually two days a month and
we would do it in outreach and we'd go
to a city go to Atlanta you do CNN
editorial board you would do Georgia
State you know what's the the one of the
great universities that was there we'd
do a couple of things with them we'd do
the Atlanta Constitution and then we'd
do something with some other gathering
maybe the business executives from
northern National Security or whatever
it was and we we really worked hard at
that and you just beat yourself up doing
that you have to have a very efficient
structure I mean I'd combo guys with me
all the time so you're staying in touch
but but I felt it was very important and
we did that most of the major cities in
America thank you sir we're going to
turn it over to the audience for a
couple questions and then close so if we
could get the first question from the
audience Thank You general Burgess thank
you for being here as a former Marine
Semper Fidelis semper hai for the past
three decades the foreign policy
establishment has taken it for granted
that global engagement is good for the
United States the 2016 election however
suggests that the American people might
not feel the same way as a strategic
leader how would you what big idea would
you use to bring our foreign and
military policy in line with the values
and interests of the American middle
class and how would you communicate it
and they could be start again by being
first with the truth you probably have a
decent approach and by this I mean that
political leaders and policy makers I
think have tended to focus on the pluses
of trade deals of globalism of opening
our economy to others and then welcoming
other countries into it shine into the
WTO and and so forth and so on but have
sometimes been a little bit less
forthright about the fact that there are
losers as well as winners when you have
a trade deal and I think you have to go
into this and this is a challenge
because the losers this is an
existential issue for them I mean in
NAFTA once we didn't have to I think
every shoemaking company in America
except for maybe one in New England
literally went out of business the
clothing manufacturers in North Carolina
and the eastern coast went out of
business again there were there were
significant shifts and certain sectors
were completely decimated and I think
what you have to do is say look here's
what is going to happen again to the
best of your predictive ability then say
in view of that we are going to have
there's something called taa Trade
Adjustment Assistance that is going to
be longer and more substantial than we
have ever done it in the past we are
going to help these sectors that are
affected to relocate to re-skill to
adapt and to learn and so forth and
those that you can't we will be with
them for life but I think that's the
kind of approach that you have to have
rather than just this kind of simplistic
again assumption as you noted that
globalism is good well actually it's not
for everybody
some are literally losing their
livelihoods because of that beyond that
I mean I think right now we have to
acknowledge as an example that many of
our hopes and aspirations for China's
entry into the global trading and World
Trade Organization and the rest of this
that as they got more in meshed in trade
as they were more prosperous as they
engage more in the world that inevitably
they would become more open more
transparent more you know like us and
that actually has not been the case and
and again you can talk about the
messaging and the message discipline and
some of the rhetoric and all the rest of
that without question but I think this
administration is the first that is
actually doing something to reflect that
the challenges that some of this has
created for certain sectors of the
United States I am a globalist I do
believe that the the US should continue
to lead the rules-based international
war I do believe that that rules-based
international word has served the world
reasonably well since it was established
in the wake of a 50-year period which
saw two world wars in the Great
Depression but I also acknowledge that
it is not without costs it is not
without downsides as well as upsides and
that if others are allowed to lead the
rules-based organization or
international order they may well change
the rules in ways that will not
necessarily be advantageous to us now
again could you do this with a little
less brinksmanship could you you know
etc etc sure but it does need to be to
be acknowledged and I think it was
necessary that that this sentiment
in the country which is substantial
enough obviously to have an impact on
national and local elections is actually
observed acknowledged and then that
there are actions taken as a result of
that again I say that as somebody who
does believe in that rules-based
international work by the way I tend to
believe that one of the biggest
challenges today a world that has
revisionist powers Islamist extremists
growing cyber threats domestic populism
which is really challenging democracies
in many places of the world dysfunction
in Washington and various respects all
of that that that one of the biggest
challenges is actually the strain and
stress on the rules-based international
order at a time when America not just
the administration but Americans fairly
substantial numbers of them have some
reservations about or at least questions
about whether or not we should continue
to to lead it again I believe we should
I do believe in the freedoms that we
enjoy along with the veterans here
obviously have been felt privileged to
have to protect those in a sense and by
serving in the military believed that
they're you know the best for mankind
and all the rest of this but but have to
note that again all of our different
aspirations have not necessarily come to
pass and beyond that I mean we just have
to also acknowledge the biggest single
shift strategically right now in the
overall context is that we are back in
an era of renewed great power rivalries
principally of course the strategic
competition between the US and China
which we should also note that we're
also our number one trading partner so
this is a very different competition
from that say between the west and the
east during Soviet days but it's also
the resurgence of Russia it's the
gradual rise of India shift of other
great powers around the world and those
dynamics are important and this is what
we've got to try to explain to folks
while being upfront in recognizing that
again they're people disadvantaged by
some of these deals and and and by
one's economy to the rest of the world
and therefore you need to take care of
those people better than we have and
that's the whole reason that you have
people that are so outraged at what has
taken place so we're almost out of times
I wanted to close with one last question
yep you have over 40 veterans sitting
before you today how can we as private
citizens and as private businesses
better serve veterans who return from
combat well I think by the way KKR has a
vets at work program I'm privileged to
be the chairman of that others candidly
do the work but you know we do a lot of
the it's you know welcome to the real
world but I do I mean I'm the I do chair
of the meetings the VTC is the the
hiring fairs and all the rest of this
and it has made a huge difference our
portfolio companies all of course in the
US these are have hired over 53,000
veterans and spouses because we count
spouses as well we think that's another
important component and another element
to which we have some obligation but all
of that is based on on a fact that it's
not just the right thing to do to hire
veterans it's actually the smart thing
to do from a business perspective
veterans obviously bring a host of
experiences expertise they've been
tested often in combat they've shown up
for work and done early morning physical
training in the rain and the cold all of
these other reasons I think that that
again they're very attractive to
business but what we then need to do is
we need to try to provide them career
opportunities not just jobs and sadly
what happens for a fair number of our
veterans especially those who are
married might have a couple of kids and
they get out and they're worried and
they haven't done all the prep they
should have because we keep them working
up until the final weeks and then they
finally get the transition program and
all of a sudden the uniforms off and you
know they've also lost the sense of
mission larger than itself the privilege
of doing it with others who feel the
same way in a sense of identity the
comes from wearing a uniform so you're
out there and they jump at the first job
that comes along and then hate life
while guarding a parking lot for the
next 20 years we need to provide them
again career opportunities and the
difference is that a career opportunity
as a the chance for advancement and it's
one in which they can advance if we
provide them the training the education
the mentoring affiliation groups focus
groups and all the rest of that within
that firm so give them that kind of
opportunity and I think that's the way
to discharge the responsibility really I
I mean it's a sacred obligation I think
really to veterans who again keep in
mind in the post 9/11 period have raised
the right hand and taken an oath at a
time of war knowing that they were very
likely to be asked to go off to war and
sometimes to do it again and again and
again as during the surge years of
constant deployments these are great
Americans they are typically the 1% you
know we talk a lot about the 1%
privilege to mingle with some of those
they're in the New York financial
community there's this other 1% and
that's the percentage of Americans that
are in uniform at any given time and
again we do owe a lot to them they they
really are as Tom Brokaw said to me
actually he was with us again I think it
was the first year or Iraq
he took him around and showed him all
the different tasks that our soldiers
were performing everything from tactical
operations to nation-building and a host
of others helping with local governance
and restoration and basic services and
repair of facilities and everything else
and at the end of that I remember he's
getting on a helicopter and the blades
turning any shouts in my ear he says you
know general those World War 2 veterans
that I wrote about they may have been
the greatest generation but surely these
individuals are America's new greatest
generation I firmly believe that I feel
very privileged to have to serve with
them on the battlefield and I remember
remain very very grateful to them for
what they have done but I want to end
this the way that I started it is to
remind you of the extraordinary
privilege that you have
we talked about luck being what happens
in preparation we meets opportunity
I can imagine fewer better ways to
prepare than doing what it is that you
all are doing right here and again how
fortunate is that you are in one of
these seats here today there is that
saying in the scriptures about you know
of whom - of whom to whom much is given
much is expected and much is expected of
you because of what it is that you're
able to do here and I'm very confident
because of my practice of affirmative
leadership that you'll you will prove us
all right thanks
[Applause]
[Music]